So the question was,
um,
positive emotions mediated by dopamine.
When you're advancing towards something,
say,
or when you have a cue that something
good is about to happen,
what is the system that mediates
positive emotion at the satiation level?
Yup.
Okay.
Well,
let's start with the satiation issue
that seems most deregulated by
Serotonin.
The opiate issue is there are other
forms of specific reward that don't seem
to be merely motivated or merely
underpinned by dopamine.
And the opiate system would be one of
those.
There's an oxytocin system as well.
So there are other biochemical systems
that are involved in more specific forms
of reward.
But the thing that's common among
instances that make it appear that
you're moving forward is the
dopaminergic element,
roughly speaking.
And then one of the things that happens
if you're higher in Serotonin because
you're more dominant,
is that you're more satiated all the
time.
That's why people who are low in the
dominance hierarchy with decreased
levels of Serotonin are more impulsive
and also more emotionally dysregulated.
They're more impulsive because,
hey,
you take your positive thing when you
can get it.
Okay.
And so they're,
they're more dissatisfied.
They're more looking for anything that
will produce a positive outcome.
And then they're also more likely to
experience diffused negative emotion.
Partly because their serotonin systems
are lower,
indicating their tenuous status in the
dominance hierarchy.
Meaning that everything they do that's
uncertain is far more dangerous.
So this is also why it's very difficult
often when you're trying to treat
someone who's depressed.
Because you could say there's not much
difference between being depressed and
existing in the biochemical state.
That being at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy would produce.
In fact they're the same thing.
Well then the question is,
are you depressed or are you just at the
bottom of a dominance hierarchy?
Because those are not that like the,
the symptomatology is very,
very similar.
But the cause and the cure are not the
same.
You know,
cause you might be at the bottom of the
dominant Turkey because you're just,
everything about your life is ruined.
So,
and of course your suffering.
Are you depressed?
No,
not exactly.
You just have nowhere to go.
So
other questions?
Yes.
Pursue Muller.
They don't produce this residence.
Okay.
So the question is,
why don't,
why do people pursue rewards that don't
produce this resonance?
They don't have a value hierarchy.
So pleasure.
It's a good example.
Those kids that were brought there were
lost.
So they didn't,
they didn't have anywhere to go.
They didn't have an identity.
So they default to local pleasure,
and that's better than none.
Although the problem with local
pleasure,
wild as the narrative made clearer is
that you better look out if you're
impulsive because it's going to kick
back on your heart.
And the reason is you're only
considering the immediate timeframe.
And the problem is,
is that things propagate across all the
timeframes.
And so just because something works
really well,
this second cocaine for example,
doesn't mean that it's a tenable
solution to the class of all problems.
So usually,
often people pursue local pleasure
because that's the best they can
imagine.
It's the best they've been taught.
They don't see another alternative.
So it could be ignorance.
It can be,
they don't want to adopt the
responsibility because part of the
problem with working at every level of
the hierarchy simultaneously is that
it's,
well,
it's like dancing to a very complex
waltz,
let's say.
You have to be paying attention to a
very large number of things
simultaneously and doing things right.
It requires responsibility.
And so you know,
that's,
it's a pain.
It's a weight.
Part of the reason people drink alcohol
is to get rid of their responsibility.
I mean that's,
you know,
you hear people drink because they have
problems.
It's like,
yeah,
no.
Some people drink because they're
anxious and alcoholics drink because
they're in withdrawal.
But young people drink because they're
sick and tired of being responsible
because it's annoying.
It's like,
so I'll drink enough.
I won't care about the medium to
longterm consequences because alcohol,
that's exactly what alcohol does.
It doesn't make you ignorant of the
medium to longterm consequences,
but it makes you not care about them.
And partly it's because it dampens
anxiety,
so it dampens anxiety,
leaves your positive emotion circuits
intact.
So then you can go out there and do
stupid,
fun things.
And that's like,
that's a party really.
Let's go do stupid fun things.
That's a party.
But the medium to longterm consequences
are,
it's risky.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't do it,
but it's risky.
So yeah,
they don't know better.
That's the answer I would say.
So yes.
Well,
if you're talking about responsibility,
it seems like that
balance of person to a certain frame.
Now that's why conservatives and
liberals don't get along
because conservatives do bind themselves
to a particular frame and they're
conscientious and low and openness.
And the Liberals say,
doesn't that just bind you to a
particular frame?
And it's like,
yeah,
that that's,
it does.
And that's a problem.
So yes,
but in terms of being aware of the
multiple levels,
um,
it takes within a frame,
it takes a certain amount of tolerance
of the unbearable present for that to
reach the edge of that frame,
to force a person to see a different
frame.
Because that's something that sentence.
Yes.
And that's,
that's actually where I stopped today
because that's a,
that's exactly right.
So you're,
you're,
it's good because both the questions you
asked indicated that you're sort of at
the next step in the,
in the logic process.
Cause you asked about the relationship
between these frames with,
with,
you know,
in relationship to one another and that
is the next issue.
It's like
there's something about responsibility
and individuality,
but I'm curious about responsibility
implies a connection to other people.
Okay.
Well what are the things,
one of the things we are going to talk
about in the classes is how you address
the problem that you just described,
which is that this is the Peter Pan
Story,
roughly speaking is Peter Pan is this
magical boy pan means pan is the god of
everything roughly speaking.
Right.
And so it's not an accident that he has
the name Pat and he's the boy that won't
grow up and he's magical.
Well that's because children are
magical.
They can be anything.
They're nothing but potential.
And Peter Pan doesn't want to give that
up.
Why?
Well,
he's got some adults around them,
but the main adult is captain hook.
Well who the hell wants to grow up to be
captain?
Hark.
First of all,
you've got a hook.
Second year a tyrant and third you're
chased by the dragon of chaos with a
clock in its stomach,
right?
The crocodile,
it's already got a piece of view.
Well that's what happens when you get
older.
Time has already got a piece of you and
eventually it's got a taste for you and
eventually it's going to eat you.
And so hook is so traumatized by that
that he can't help but be a tyrant.
And then Peter Pan looks out traumatized
Herc and says,
well no,
I'm not sacrificing my childhood for
that.
So that's fine,
except he ends up killing in lost boys.
It never loud.
Well,
Neverland doesn't exist and who the hell
wants to be king of the lost boys?
And he also sacrifices the possibility
that to help it real relationship with a
woman,
because that's Wendy Wright and she's
kind of conservative middle class London
dwelling girl.
She wants to grow up and have kids and
have a life.
She accepts her mortality,
she accepts her maturity.
Peter Pan has to contend himself with
Tinkerbell.
She doesn't even exist.
She's like,
she's like the fairy of porn.
She doesn't exist.
She's the substitute for the real thing.
And so,
but the dichotomy that you're talking
about,
it's very tricky because there's a
sacrificial element in maturation,
right?
You have to sacrifice the pleura
potentiality of childhood for the
actuality of a frame.
And the question is,
well,
why would you do that?
Well,
one reason is it happens to you whether
you do it or not,
you can either choose your damn
limitation
or you can let it take you unaware when
you're 30 or even worse when you're 40
and then that is not a happy day.
You see,
I see people like this,
and I think it's more and more common in
our culture because people can put off
Matt maturity without suffering and
immediate penalty.
But all that happens is the penalty
accrues.
And then when it finally hits,
it just wallops you.
Because when you're 25 you could be an
idiot.
It's no problem.
Even when you're out in a job search,
it's like,
well,
you don't have any experience in.
You're kind of clueless.
It's,
yeah,
you're young.
You know?
It's no problem.
We can,
that's what young people are like,
but they're full of potential.
Okay,
well now you're the same person at 30
it's like people aren't so thrilled
about you at that point.
It's like what the hell have you been
doing for the last 10 years?
Well,
I'm just as clueless as I was when I was
22 it's,
yeah,
but you're not 22 you're an old infant.
Right?
And that's an ugly thing and old infant.
So they,
the reason,
part of the reason you choose your damn
sacrifice because the sacrifice is
inevitable,
but at least you get to choose it.
And then there's something that's even
more complex than that in some sense is
that the problem with being a child is
that all you are is potential and it's
really low resolution.
You could be anything but you're not
anything.
So then you go and you do adopt an
apprenticeship,
roughly speaking,
and then you become at least you become
something.
And when you're something that makes the
world opened up to you again.
You know,
like if you're a really good plumber,
then you end up being far more than a
plumber,
right?
You end up being a good employer.
Not,
not that plumbers,
I'm not putting plumbers town.
It's like more power to plumbers.
They've saved more lives than doctors.
So hygiene,
right?
So you know,
if you're a really good plumber,
well then you have some employees,
you run a business,
you,
you make you,
you train some other people,
you enlarge their lives.
You're kind of a pillar of the
community.
You,
you have your family.
It's,
you can,
once you pass through that narrow
training period,
which narrows you and constricts you and
develops you at the same time,
then you can come out the other end with
a bunch of new possibility at hell at
hand.
And you haven't talked about that.
A thought that the proper part of the
proper path of development in the last
half of life was to rediscover the child
that you left behind as you were
apprenticing.
And so then you get to be something and
regain that potential at the same time.
Very,
very smart.
While he was very,
So that's very wise,
very wise thing to know.